innovation management practice but it's
also a university lecture it's part of
the special series or invention
innovation and creativity it was
co-sponsored by the program in
engineering and technology innovation
management the department of biomedical
engineering college of engineering and
mill college of science as well as the
office of the provost for education
tonight's speaker is matt matt is a
nocturnal easing alum of Carnegie Mellon
undergraduate degree in joint degree in
chemical engineering
he also has a PhD for a class titled
animation edge and in practice he is
certainly a skilled practitioner in
innovation innovation management having
worked as a researcher manager organ and
organizational work process development
and breakthrough innovation for
practicing for 17 years he has also
served as the vice chair of the
Industrial Research Institute's
innovation news network currently he's
focused on business innovation as the
CFO a start-up footwear company and it's
also a consultant for the hacker
international capital investment bank
located and is topic today is something
thanks ed yeah so this is an opportunity
for me to talk to you guys about two
things I'm really really passionate
about one is buggy and another one is
innovation and this statement is really
true and I have you know found myself
saying that and over and over again in
different kind of professional
situations in my career where I think
wow you know this is similar to what
happened in this story or that story
back when we were doing buggy and it's
also the excuse to tell me a lot of
stories a lot or tell you guys a lot of
stories from college so first a little
bit more of an introduction on me I want
to lead with my buggy credentials first
and then I'm going to talk about my
innovation credentials so and this is a
picture when I we started put together
this presentation a friend of mine who
one of our drivers from the 90s had all
the spirit photographs and she was
scanning everything in so I would send
her the presentation I'm like you know
how to find the find the right
photographs to put them in and this one
was the embarrassing photo of math so I
think she found that the right picture
of me so I was so one of the coach
and one of the founders of spirit buggy
spear as an organization goes back for a
while but we hadn't done buggy until 85
and we started doing buggy in 1985 we
ended up winning men's in 87 and we
ended up winning um women and men's both
that well or woman's in 86 and 87 now
although I wasn't here for it there's
also one of the builders of a buggy and
I'll talk a lot about this buggy called
quantum leap and quantum leap we built
it and raced it an 87 we raced it as RC
buggy and for those of you who aren't
familiar with buggy I'll give you an
introduction about buggy as well so some
of these things I'm saying about see
buggies in this ad will start to make a
little bit more sense but the cool thing
about this is this buggy set a record in
88 and it was the longest-held record in
the history of sweepstakes so I think
you know hopefully as presented I do
know a little bit about buggy and then
on innovation Eden gave you most of the
introduction already that basically I
got my PhD in chemical engineering went
to corporate R&D for Praxair which is a
really large industrial gas company
primarily what it does is take this you
know separates it into oxygen nitrogen
and then sells out to other really
really big companies and it was always
an R&D there I was an individual
contributor I was a technical manager
and I had this really interesting role
kind of an unusual role in this work
process development and tool developer
where for about four years I was able to
develop the tools that Praxair R&D used
to help them innovate so there's
stage-gate processes and there's things
called voice of the customer and I won't
go into really too much of those details
but is a really neat opportunity and
kind of an unusual opportunity to not
just be a practitioner of an innovation
not just go out and try to do innovation
but to really think about it
conceptually to really think about you
know what's the heart of innovation and
how can you teach people to be
innovative and what kind of tools do you
need to to give them so i'll be sharing
a lot of that with you and then most
recently to try to get you know for me
was to have some new experiences and
kind of round myself out i've been doing
more entrepreneurial stuff now it's i
still consider it innovation and i'll
talk a little bit about that too it's a
little bit more on the business side of
innovation trying to create new
businesses but I've been doing that most
recently so here's the
uh what is bugging and hopefully you
guys will do I got a light nope
nevermind and I'll talk a little bit
about it the history of bug you but just
so you can kind of see it this is a map
well touching so this is tech streak so
that's dia fodder Margot Morrison go
through Schenley Park and then move back
here on through and it's a sport and
it's a sport unique to this campus and
it's a combination of a human powered
vehicle race and a gravity race so
basically what happens is from a
standing start at the bottom of tech you
push this buggy up a hill and then right
about here there's a transition where
one person releases the buggy and then a
second person comes it starts pushing it
so you get a little bit of a relay race
kind of saying takes it over the crest
of the hill and then throws the buggy
down you can see this person here kind
of throwing buggies and goes and what's
called the freeroll so now it's a
gravity race so now what might be more
familiar to you guys who haven't you
know don't know about buggy yet big like
a soap box derby race right so bucks the
race you build a car go straight
downhill right now this is a little bit
more complicated because obviously there
are lots and lots of turns so it's not a
straight course like soap box derby is
and then one of the kind of cruel things
about it is that the lowest portion of
the of the race which is right about
here so you're going too fast if you can
the gravity race he's going approaching
40 miles an hour you have to make a
really really sharp turn to go through
this area called the shoot so there's
always kind of issues about stability of
getting through there then what'll end
up happening and here's a picture of it
go to the shoot but you'll come back up
back down here there's another person
will then pick it up run behind the
buggy it's a hill 3 and there's two
other people that finish the hill on
going up through tech and then finally
here's the finish finishes right here
one of the interesting things about
again a cruel thing about the way the
race is run is one of the rules is is
when the buggy crosses the finish line
the last pusher the hill 5 person has to
be touching the buggy has to be touching
the handlebars so it's one of these
dramatic things if you know these
buggies are so well built it you can hit
a couple of times it'll actually go
faster than someone can run and there's
these people at the end diving to try to
touch the buggy and it gets pretty
dramatic so this is what buggy is now
why is this important to the campus in a
school maybe that doesn't have a lot of
tradition this is a really big tradition
at carnegie mellon goes almost back to
the beginning of the beginning of the
school so it started in the 1920s
competition the wheels had to be four
wheels only fraternities could enter and
a lot of it was about pageantry
obviously is the guys riding a fish they
don't look like that no one is riding a
fish right now then it started to change
a little bit the current course was
established in 20 1928 there was some
other weird well from my perspective
weird rules that they had at one point
in time you had to demonstrate your
skill at changing wheels one point in
time of the course the buggy had to stop
you had to flip its wheels and then keep
going so a lot of changes but finally in
the 30s you ended up getting buggies now
that started to look kind of like modern
buggies that are three wheeled and it
started to be a little bit more
conventional with you know a prone drive
or not somebody standing up it came a
lot more like what it is today back in
the 70s couple things happen in the 70s
there were female drivers and there were
female push teams and why in drive is
really important this picture here is a
picture that I took from a presentation
by Tom Wood who's a pike alum and really
really big in buggy circles and this is
the illustration he uses about why women
drivers are used all those people in
that picture are pyka drivers and you
can kind of see you know as soon as you
start going to you know two women you
could get lots of small people so it's
lighter and that ends up becoming a
really really important part of you know
one of the basic kind of things with
this is with a buggy since I'm a lot of
that race you're pushing it when you're
pushing something that's lighter you
know it's a lot easier to push there's a
big advantage to that and women sorry to
push as well and then finally the last
really major rule
change that affected what buggy is was
an 89 just after I'd left and they had
outlawed two-wheel buggies and the
reason with two will buggies kind of
like bicycles or modified bicycles they
have a tendency you flop over a lot so
they're not very stable but they can be
they can be actually go pretty fast
especially when they're in a fairing so
from a safety perspective just from the
lack of stability rather than trying to
figure out how to make them stable they
just were outlawed so there's a bit of a
history here's the course record um I
wish I could still when I first put them
together this presentation I was able to
say that quantum leap still had the
course record we had a 206 something
which is I have to point that that's
that that's that blue dot right there
but since then last couple years the
records actually been broken which is
pretty exciting so the rate the whole
race takes a little bit over a 2 minutes
to run that's a picture of the buggy
that holds the record so again just a
little a little introduction at least
but what buggy is now I want to start
talking about innovation and when I
first want to do is try to get clear on
some definitions people I think have
different ideas of what innovation means
and sometimes you think you're talking
saying the same thing when everyone's
talking about innovation you may be
talking about very different things and
for me this is a mental model that
actually a colleague of mine got my
native Jim white came up with at praxair
and I really really really like this
model I don't think this is a really
succinct way of explaining what
innovation is and as an engineer I like
to see it in an equation format right so
the whole point is innovation is
invention plus application equals equals
the innovation so the invention part of
it just need a simple in a dictionary
definition when you're inventing what
are you doing you're bringing something
new you bring something novel to the
world so that inventors are really
really important part of innovation part
of it is you're doing something new
you're doing so that's never been done
before but just that app just that act
of creating something new really is an
innovation you have to take that
invention and apply it to the real world
in order to have any kind of innovation
and Pratt and apply it in the world
if you're stewing it successfully you do
successful innovation you're applying it
to the world in a way that generates
value now that value can be monetary I
mean I tend to think about things that
way from you know being in this private
equity world and you know corporate
world we tend to look at dollar signs at
the end of it but it could be value like
winning a buggy race it could be value
like getting men to the moon and back
safely but still it's this invention
plus that application it's a really
really important part to understand that
it's not just the invention part it's
taking that invention and really
applying it and making something happen
so I'm going to give you some examples
of and of what innovation is to kind of
hopefully prove my point to you guys
that it is in both in the invention and
application this is an example of some
work that i did when i was at praxair
and basically it's pretty cool
technology it's a pretty neat pretty it
was a pretty neat project to work on but
it's a device that we call up time and
basically what it is it's a little gizmo
that set in the valve that's in a gas
cylinder and it's a little safety device
and basically what you can do you can
take a cylinder you can open up the
cylinder valve and nothing will come out
of it unless you pull a vacuum on that
open you have to basically pull a vacuum
opens up a little mechanical switch and
it allows flow reason why this is
important or reason why this is relevant
is you have to understand its
application and it's specifically
designed for iron in planters which are
basically kind of the heart of a
semiconductor fab and I on implants
based in planters or how you end up in
pedo silicon chips and basically what
you do if you want to put arsenic into
your chip you take a gas and say it's
arcing blow it apart in an ionization
chamber so you just get it to its
constituent ions mass let the arsenic I
on and then you accelerate it into the
chip at something like three million
five billion volts and that's how you
implant these things the reason why
that's a problem is all the gases or
just about all the gases are used for
implant are really toxic really
pyrophoric really corrosive like really
nasty deadly gases matter of fact a lot
of the chemicals there's not most of the
chemicals used to make semiconductors
are pretty difficult to deal with and
the way a semiconductor fab tip
deals with this is you'll have your fab
floor which will have all the
semiconductor tools all this stuff it's
processing the silicon wafers then in
the basement our gas cabinets and
chemical cabinets so all of them are
isolated and especially vent alized
ventilated containers but you can't do
that with an ion implant machine because
then that gas cabinet has to be at the
same voltage is the ion chamber so it's
at three million volts so now you have a
gas cabinet you have gas lines there are
three million volts that are sneaking
through your fab so that's a really
really bad problem so it's the one
exception as far as I know it's the only
exception in a semiconductor fab where
your gas cabinet is actually attached to
the unit operations actually attached to
the ion implanter ok now this creates
another problem which is you've got to
change that thing out you run out of gas
and you need to put more are seen in or
phosphine or whatever now you have to
take a cylinder of gas and walk it
through your fab floor now as I said
before it's really really toxic really
corrosive you open up that bottle you
let gas out in your fab you're gonna can
really hurt people and kill people and
you'll have to shut down the fab you
know and you know an hour of fab time is
millions of dollars in profit with a big
semiconductor fab there's a lot of big
issues associated with that so the idea
is now this is a safety feature right so
now you can take a cylinder put a lot of
Arsene into it a really nice you know
supply of arcing and again if you walk
it down to fab floor and you offer some
makes the trip you have some some
mistake and the valve opens nothing's
going to happen again because you have
to suck on this thing you have to pull a
vacuum on it and I named planners
running out vacuum so it all kind of
works so going into this isn't an
innovation right so the invention of
inventions pretty clearly there's
patents and there's a little gizmo and
you can get this patent and kind of
understand how that gizmo works so you
have an invention but that's not
innovation you have to apply it here's a
old sales literature that would appear
in a semiconductor trade magazine so
it's your marketing it you're selling it
to people you're creating a business
around it so you really are taking this
invention and applying into the real
world and they produce innovation and
again in this case i'm using i'm
measuring that value that external value
in terms of dollars and it's real data i
can't really tell you exactly what the
numbers are but if you look at time this
would be tens of months and dollars are
tens of millions of dollars so a pretty
classic
view of innovation your corporate new
product development now I also think you
can be innovative around other things is
what I'm doing right now currently so
there is actually an invention you know
something you can really wrap your heads
around there's some technology that
actually goes into these shoes but what
I've been involved with is really the
application part of it and there's
actually what we're setting up is a it's
a picture of us setting up our booth at
the wsa which is the world shoe in
apparel comfort or trade show you know
something that is an engineering never
really thought I would be at at a shoe
trade show but we were at a few trade
show again applying it creating a
business finding you know setting up
distribution all that sort of stuff
you're applying this technology you're
applying this invention this shoe and
trying to make a business out of it and
then the innovation part of it well
we're trying I don't know if we're
successful yet so that's where we have
you know little thing this night this is
my hope since it's in the middle but
again you know here's more of a business
oriented more entrepreneurial thing but
it's still innovation and here's my
argument that the buggy is innovation so
using that same you know formalism you
have an invention in this case this is a
picture of quantum leap right so we
invented we created we created that bug
you create something new then you got to
apply it right so it's not it's not just
having a buggy you have to have races
you have to compete so here's a
competing that's an application of this
technology of that invention and then
finally here it's the innovation here
the value you know that's a picture of
us celebrating and this one I when I
when I sent to my friend Elizabeth was
dancing Dave so she knew immediately
what picture that was and that's Dave
sours who's actually the chairman the
year after me so he's the one who was
the chairman who actually set the record
but this is this is the year before so
the innovation here are the value that
you gain you'll buggy was was victory
mean that's the external measure of
success but again innovation there's an
invention component there's an
application opponent so buggy is
innovate and innovative activity so just
again one argument first argument I want
to make is all of these things you know
certainly new product development I
think you can all wrap your heads around
say that yeah thatthat's innovation but
they can I think being an entrepreneur
could be innovative and I certainly
think a buggy is innovative I want to
give you a another kind of theoretical
concert to start to thinking about
things and this is really a way to think
about organizations now I've given you a
conceptual model about innovation now
I'm going to talk about kind of
organizations and this is based on a
work called activity theory which is
kind of a meta theory that comes out of
soviet-era psychology it actually comes
out from the 20s then in the 80s and 90s
it got picked up and applied by a lot of
Scandinavian researchers and it got
applied to a lot of like human computer
interaction shared work which is kind of
how I got involved in it and it's a
basic way of looking at how people
organize themselves to do something and
there's some at least some face validity
to it where you can take a look at work
you know what's what's what's what's the
what are the elements of work you if
you're trying to make a periodic table
of work what is it there's an individual
two acts on a task to produce an outcome
that's pretty straightforward but in
most things we do certainly in buggy
certainly a new product development it's
not just any one person doing that you
know acting on that task for an outcome
there's a group of people so now you
have an individual and you have a team
the team is acting on the task and then
the team and the individual are acting
on each other so this is kind of an
intro that the kind of a first layer of
activity series and one of the things
that teaches you is when you start to
look at activity you look at work
there's really two at least initially
two things you can take a certain
focusing on take a look at the
organization and you can take a look at
the task so the first stuff i'm going to
talk about is I'm going to talk I'm now
going to go in and talk about buggy is a
task and kind of get into this at least
the buggy people we're here should enjoy
it a little bit about what you have to
do to create a buggy and all that I'm
going to talk about that and then after
that I'm going to talk about the
organization and then tie it back to
innovation so let's talk about buggy is
a task so there's a primary engineering
challenge and this is one of the things
that makes buggy really exciting is a
classic engineering trouble challenge
remember about you about 50 seconds or
so
Phylly is the buggy going downhill so
what's the primary thing you want to if
you a gravity racer soapbox derby
basically what you're doing is taking
the potential energy of your hill and
you're converting into kinetic energy of
your vehicle right pretty
straightforward any time that thing
flexes you've wasted you've wasted that
height into into flexing so what you
need is something that's very very rigid
right that's your primary thing it has
to be rigid now but you also for 75
seconds or so people are pushing it and
as I you know hinted before mentioned
before about why there are female
drivers now when you're pushing
something you want it as light as
possible I mean put a really really
heavy shopping cart versus a light
shopping cart it's a lot easier to push
the light shopping cart so you have a
fundamental engineering challenge how do
you make something light and rigid you
know classic problem um there's other
issues and I'll talk a little bit about
them too if you look on the downhill
part of it after you make a rigid buggy
the next thing you need is low rolling
resistance wheels and I'll talk in more
detail about that because that's a real
you know hot topic and buggy and there's
lots of Secrets associated with that you
need to make it recently aerodynamic
again these things go around 40 miles an
hour so you start to get in the area
that aerodynamics matter a lot of
different shapes work but you still need
to make an aerodynamic and as I'd
mentioned before when you're at the
lowest point of the course and you're
going the fastest you have to make this
really really really sharp turn so you
have to be able to make this thing that
it can stable and actually get through
this turn without wiping out and when
you go to carnival if you guys do the
carnival a lot of people will they'll go
they'll go in the shoot and they're
there because well the buggies are
moving the fastest but they're also
waiting for buggies to spin out and wipe
out and kind of exciting right but even
if you don't wipe out even if these
buggies don't you know twist if they
scrub speed that's also an issue right
is you kind of skate through the escape
through the turn and on the pushing side
of it think the other issue is not only
does the thing need to be light and this
is also something that was always very
very important for us in spirit was you
need to have a good pushing platform
there are buggies that are harder to
push in their buggies that are easier to
push so now do you want to make it light
you want to make it easy to push
oh here's just since I have it in the
picture one thing that's kind of
interesting talk a little bit more about
this later too if you see there's a
woman that's actually Denise Redmond
there's a flag and there's one of our
buggies I think that's ql these buggies
are so low to the ground that you can't
see over the crown of the road so to let
your driver know when to turn you have
to signal it so I actually have two
single flags and then she knows to take
their turn into the shoot so again what
do you need you need a light and rigid
buggy so if you start looking at
technology solutions it's really kind of
only a handful of technologists kind of
makes sense one of the things is let's
all talk to the second bullet point
first materials what you drive you to
materials that are really light and
really rigid and really when it all
comes down to it it's aluminum you know
you can also get some like special
beryllium alloys and titanium and crazy
things like that but basically it's
aluminum and then it's composite
materials my favorite being the
composite material part of it and then
if you look at a structure part of it
structurally how do you make something
that's light and rigid okay one again
you have the right kind of materials but
there's really kind of three ways to do
it and there's kind of hybrids between
them but one is to make a Space Frame a
truss right like a bridge you know
another is to make a tube you know tubes
can be really light and then another way
to do it what you've seen is basically
kind of a skateboard design again there
can kind of be hybrids of hybrids of all
those our choice and in this again the
buggy quantum belief that held the
record for so many years basically it's
a carbon-fiber tube it's a monocoque
it's a tube made out of you know getting
made out of this you know really light
and strong composite material so again
not only do you get into issues of you
know interesting design and you know and
challenging design when you do this
stuff do you get workmanship ends up
becoming an important part of it
actually building these things now Lola
rolling resistance wheels now imagine
you've got your rigid buggy and let's
imagine that you've done a good job and
it's actually life is the buggy goes
down that hill what happens for each of
your tires is there's a little flat spot
right because it's weighted down
then is that buggy rolls the flat spot
kind of moves right or the tire moves
right it kind of rotates through so
what's happening constantly on each of
those tires is they're expanding and
contracting you're getting this
expansion and contraction and any time
you do this you're going to get energy
loss there's going to be hysteresis loss
in the in those tires and what you want
is you want to minimize those energy
losses you want to minimize that loss
and again because now again the
potential energy instead of going to
kinetic energy is going to the losses in
your tires so what you need is you need
something where you can minimize those
energy losses but still get through the
shoot and there's actually even gets a
little bit more if there's a reason like
for example you know conceptually maybe
you could say oh you put steel rims on
something right so they're not going to
flex you know I can get an energy loose
loss but you have no grip you have no
ability to get into the get through
the chute there's also some other other
issues kind of around that as well it's
a little bit more complicated but
because a real big challenge how do you
have I mean once you have a light and
rigid buggy what what makes a freeroll
are your wheels what is the typical
technology you use solid polyurethane
tires it's talk about the tires itself
not the hub right what is actually
contacting the pavement solid
polyurethane solid rubber or pneumatic
wheels and actually I've had experience
in all of them and then not only that
there's another level of complication
that it's not just finding this wheel
you then a wheel and of itself doesn't
let's just like roll all that well you
then have to go and actually treat the
wheel can chemically treat it you can
heat treat it if you have pneumatics you
can play around with gas pressure and
what gases you have and you can do an
experiment it's kind of neat if you have
like a superb all right drop it down and
measure its rebound so maybe the super
ball comes up to sixty percent of its
original height now I'll take that same
Super Bowl soak it in gasoline for a few
hours bounce it it's now going to come
up to about seventy percent and so
that's why you get these chemical
treatments similarly you take it you
heat it up a little bit it's going to
bounce better so now one of the things
that and this ends up well and this ends
up being an area in particular that's a
really really closely guarded secret
about
the organization's so what compounds are
they using on their tires and what they
treat it ends up being a very very proof
top for proprietary technology and very
very closely guarded and here's
something came from the 85 buggy book so
this is the first entry for spirit and
the buggy book is is the catalog or not
saying the right thank you is the
program that's for every races they're
gonna have a program so every
organization you know lists you know
who's in their organization what they
plan on doing it has all the races and
heat and all that sort of stuff so
that's the program for the event in
carnival and this is a part of from fun
where we rode and we're taking some
people on on campus but what I
highlighted was a mr. Jim Underwood and
luckily for a spirit Jim Underwood was
my neighbor growing up in Akron Ohio and
Jim Underwood and his family were really
really well known in soap box derby and
a lot of the technology this whole
originally like how you know to heat and
treat wheels people have been heating
and treating wheels in soap box derby
long before it ever came into it came
into buggy so one of the things it was
really important for us and when the
reasons why we were able to get you know
kind of fast kind of quick is we knew
Jim I knew Jimmy waiting would talk to
them we found out stuff right so couple
points on this is you have you know
proprietary knowledge is part of the
task of buggy but so is external
relationships and you know and uh using
you know partnering with people
externally there's some additional
design elements that I haven't mentioned
one basic configuring is gear
configuration issue like is it and
typically there are either tricycles or
reverse tricycles right now it used to
be a little bit more complicated because
people would have their two-wheel
buggies or affordable buggies or three
well buggies now all buggies are three
wheel and the reason is going back to
that low rolling resistance thing four
wheels have more rolling resistance than
three wheels you're not allowed to use
two wheels so you want to use the fewer
enough fewest number of wheels you can
which ends up being three so then you
have to figure out your configuration
and then from your configuration you
have to worry about steer
right so that gets another complication
you also have to have brakes on these
the hope is you never ever ever use a
break in a race because obviously that
slows you down but from a safety
perspective somehow somebody spins out
in front of yet you got to be able to
stop it or you're going to hit the buggy
in front of you so you're required to
have brakes and you have to design him
at all frankly we've had problems I've
had a this buggy actually failed failed
to break test for us in 86 and one of
things you have to do to prove that you
what people used to do in like the 60s
70s maybe is they'd have brakes and your
buggy would get approved and that they
take the brakes off and they wouldn't
racing with brakes because the idea was
if there's no brakes the driver won't
have any you know can't use them so you
don't have to worry about it right but
you know but so they imposed a new
regulation which is immediately after
the race you have to test your brakes
and it can you know and people fail it
and we failed it and we failed it for a
really you know well I we thought we
were doing the right thing which is that
sting which is the buggy that I one with
an 87 had a really awful design of its
break but it was a drop break and
basically what that meant there was a
pivot and she would kick her legs back
and a break would drop off and actually
picked the whole back of the buggy off
and to have this whole lever arm work
there was a big cut out in the bottom of
the buggy to allow the lever to come
through and at the last minute and we
had never done this in practice our
mechanic the man who designed and built
it who's a brilliant guy actually a race
car driver Chris Winkler decided that he
wanted to make it aerodynamic so he put
little bits of tape on other side of the
break and then the break seized up and
you know we would have gotten sixth
place with that I had that had that not
happened so you have to worry about
bricks and I guess do you have to worry
about you know maintenance like one of
the awful things again we're quickly
it's funny I can point out all the awful
things we did like this buggy ilan so
buddy we got fourth place men's and one
woman's in 86 and what did we run d team
C team C team in 87 but um awful designs
like what we were thinking in order to
get this
the driver in the whole front of the
buggy actually came off and so there's a
there was like a fork on the front like
a bicycle and then of the wheels off the
fork and there's a panel and took a
little pieces of living and they were
bolted together and to get her in we
take the whole assembly off put her in
then both the thing back on it was just
a nightmare to get it aligned it was
never align right it was an awful thing
right we also when we first race first
practice with a buggy this is my friend
tom's worse yes the worst weekend of us
life well is that you failed a test
girlfriend broke up with you and then we
had three buggies all of which broke in
the same things one of which sting bent
it was really under build at the time it
literally the buggy just bent right
another one got into an accident there
was a pass tests and the other buggy hit
us and flipped over and then what
happened was really really bad the wolf
the worst was with a lawn and I don't
know how we managed to get as a vision
test you have to pass to be allowed to
practice and race these things and I
don't know how we passed because we had
cut the windshield in such a bad way
that she couldn't see out of the buggy
and then it fogged up and so she
couldn't see your flags she didn't know
where she was and she just kept going
straight and they put up barriers to
block off on what's that bridge Panther
all yeah mmm yeah the boy yes it's the
one over the hollow right and we put no
barriers to prevent cars from coming
through see somehow managed to miss the
barriers went right through the barriers
and then hit the curb going the fastest
you can enlist those big Pittsburgh curb
shattered the buggy is amazing so vision
is an important thing and another thing
another thing with I I think this is
certainly true it's certainly true about
buggy and it has to also be true about I
think just innovative really certainly
technology innovation is um it's never
going to be smooth sailing there's
always going to be mistakes and part of
and they're always going to be problems
and part of what you have to do is get
through the bad times right and so
excited was Thomas Thomas worst weekend
and
and a few hours later you know he's in
the buggy room and I have the buggy
apart and I'm looking at it and you know
it was a space frame that was shattered
and another bad idea is not only was a
way that the space room was put together
it was epoxy together and if he had done
it the right way it would have worked
but we didn't and so all the joints just
pop on this thing and you know I'm
sitting there I'm like I think we can
rebuild it so I'm scraping off epoxy you
know I'm building little pieces I'm
trying to fit this jigsaw puzzle back
together you know Tom comes in and he's
like okay then I guess it's not so bad I
guess we can keep going through this
stuff so I think that's you know I used
to say in my research group at praxair
to folks who were like new to research
it's never as good as you think it is
and it's never as bad as you think it is
right there is a time where you're doing
something you're trying to get this out
the door and everything is working
really great well just wait because
there's going to be a problem you
haven't seen and then when you have that
problem and you're in the middle of that
problem you don't know how you get
through it right so it's never as good
as you think it is it's never as bad as
you think it is but you have one of
these you have to do is you have to be
able to get through those get through
those moments and persevere and that's
that's Shawna who we forced to go down
in a buggy you couldn't see out of and I
feel really bad about that to this day
another really really important thing so
I've now take I've talked mostly about
you know technical tasks right there's
these multiple technical tasks
associated was buggy talk a little bit
about capraia terry knowledge and
external relationships another big thing
is simply put buggies don't win teams do
right so it's not just the buggy for the
race team itself and that's a picture
that the team that won men's for us in
87 you have to have a driver and you
have to have five pushers so you have to
have a buggy and a team but it's not
just that it's not just you have all the
support people I mentioned there's
people at the flag for the buggy can so
the girl can see where to turn you need
at a time right we practice constantly
and how do you know who your fastest
people are right so you have to you know
how people are just sitting out there
with a stopwatch um clearly you need
mechanics
build these things and maintain these
things you also need people to do what I
did which is care to basically kind of
run the whole organization right so
along with all these technical tasks
there's a whole bunch of non technical
tasks that go along with it I've talked
a little bit about this already but you
know along with you know within this
task this task of buggy there's a whole
bunch of safety regulations so you can't
just go out there and do whatever you
want there's safety reviews there's
inspections ahead of time there's cake
tests pass tests that you have to do
there's regulations in the race where
you can get disqualified I mentioned
before that if you have a push bar and
you don't touch the near you or you
don't touch the push bar when it goes
across the finish line you're
disqualified there's post-race safety
review so there's a whole bunch of
regulations and safety and this goes to
if I remember this goes to the flight 90
pages now something like that for people
who are right so it's a big thick
rulebook of safety and regulation stuff
that's part of buggy so kind of
reviewing what I thought it's a race so
it's a competition there's clearly an
objective measure of success it's
getting across the finish line right
with the time and you're being measured
right and then you get placed clearly
multiple technical tasks multiple roles
I mean you got you know different people
doing different things external
relationships proprietary knowledge and
it's not just technical there's multiple
non technical roles and technical tasks
and their safety and regulation these
are all things that are present in buggy
and lo and behold I want to compare
compare buggy to new product NPD stay if
I have a Mallory mentioned it's a
standard acronym for new product
development this is what I mostly did at
praxair right and there's books and
books and books and articles
peer-reviewed journals stuffs and lots
of books about how do you do new product
development and I just took you know a
couple examples that I happen to like
and kind of mash them together a little
bit to get you know a view of what are
the key things that people tell you are
important a new product development and
that's what I have up there so customer
need technical solution analysis of the
market the competition
attractiveness in the market commercial
approach right it's not just for an RD
person like me it's not just developing
something to lab how are you going to
manufacture it and you how are you going
to operate it how are you sell it and
market it right the value you know again
in a corporate new product development
value equals money for the most part
other issues safety environment
intellectual property external
partnerships assumptions and then your
resources in your schedule so this is
straight out of new product development
textbooks and if you look at it you know
all the stuff that I listed here is all
the stuff that I talked about buggy so
to me it's really a one-to-one
correspondence that all the things that
you're able to learn in buggy are all
the stuff that you have to do from a tax
standpoint you know remembering my tiffa
t center i talked about organization and
task from the task perspective
absolutely buggy is a highly you know
innovative a task that fits very well
into the kind of models if you're trying
to do any kind of engineering innovation
after you get out of here next point
want to go back to activity theory and
put give you another layer of activity
theory another kind of conceptual model
of how to look at things and really what
I'm trying to get at is is let's look at
an organization how do you analyze an
organization I've analyzes the task how
do you analyze an organization so you
recognize the whole individual team task
outcome thing activity theory posits the
existence of what they call mediators
and mediators are things that guide you
guide you and your work right and
they're both enabling and limiting and
they're both internal and external so
you can kind of think of personal work
guides once a tool like a hammer right
but it could also be a little bit more
conceptual it could be a plan so that
would because the external stuff in
terms of how you do your work you're
being guided by your both conceptual
tools and your physical tools but it's
not so those are kind of these things
that are external to you then the
internal stuff is your own skills using
those tools right and there's an
analysis that the people who an activity
theory goes through and they can kind of
produce what they call again a
these mediators is determined they are
but there's another conception where
from a based on the work of Henry
Mintzberg who's a business school
professor up at McGill where he talks
about coordinating mechanisms and he has
this kind of very ad hoc approach but
very insightful looking at organizations
talking about that the way you talk
about an organization or one way of
talking about an organization is what
are the ways that organization
coordinates its activity because
fundamentally you know what's difference
between an organization just a group of
people an organization is organized to
do something so how does that
organization takes place and he calls
those things I'd like this to him better
than mediators he calls those things
coordinating mechanisms so how does an
organization coordinating itself so I'm
going to walk through and talk to you
these are these are eight coordinating
mechanisms so based on kinds of personal
work guys it's your work tools and also
your processes as you start looking at
more of an organization rather than just
a group of people becomes a special
training that you have right then if you
look at how does that team divided
itself up to work on that task how do
you have that division of labor or a
division of labor it's really kind of
two things one is your hierarchical
structure your management structure how
do you communicate and control and work
the organization that way but really
importantly also the way you have
division and flavor you have this again
more kind of top-down hierarchy but you
have to have mechanisms of bridge so if
you can look at an organization chart
you have these boxes right and then come
time to come down there's often times
where you need to bridge from one
organization or one part of the
organization to another the term that
emits Berg uses as liaison devices so
you know typical thing we like a
cross-functional team when I did a lot
of that when I was at practice area but
you'd have a marketing person a
salesperson and operations person you
know in an RD person all on the same
team that's a liaison device so it's a
means by which you coordinate your
activity across and bridge the
organization so these are all structural
things these are kind of like how you
design the organization or and these are
all the kind of the task focused things
but I would say even more important than
that if you look at an organization or
the people side of it it's interesting
what's went to
and believe it or not they have
conferences they'd have titles like this
the conference called front end of
innovation big comforter people really
kind of get into how do you do new
product development especially on the
front end how do you figure out what to
work on and it was a panel discussion
and it was debate where the debate was
what's more important the processes you
use or the people that are involved and
there was a vote and you know hands-down
process one you know and I think part of
it is a lot of people were at that come
for like me we're process people so
you're kind of justifying your existence
or something I think another part of it
is those were actually better debaters
so it was it more you know it was easy
to convince people and then I went back
to my hotel room and I thought about it
I'm like oh that's completely wrong
clearly clearly if you look at an
organization the most important part is
not your process he's not your structure
of your organization but the people
themselves because that's where the
structure comes from right and those are
them and that's how that structure gets
used it's fun of those people so you can
look at organizations as structure and
its people and if you look at the people
apart again these coordinating
mechanisms if you look at an individual
acting on you know the team acting on
the rest of people here's you know the
external comm unit i said but these
mediators are both external and internal
so the external kind of thing is the
individual acting on the team is that
person's ability to be a leader and
leadership and influencing others the
more internal part is self motivation
you're motivating yourself so leadership
and motivation become really important
then if you look at how does the group
interact to the individual influence the
individual well what is you know the
culture your corporate culture or social
norms but you can use different words
about it but that's that you know what
are their kind of rules of engagement
rules of human engagement so typically
you know people are familiar with using
corporate culture but it's not just so
that would be again more the external
thing but it's also who you all who you
interact with your personal network of
people those are also that's also a
mediator right like I said I'm going to
go and let me tie back that conception
or you know that conceptual model of
these coordinating mechanisms and tie it
back to innovation so what are the
things that are critical for innovation
I think there's really two main areas
are really really critical for
innovation and they go back to that
invention plus application to drive
invention the one thing that you can
really effectively drive in invention to
do is to drive collaboration you got to
have an exchange of ideas that's really
really for me that's why we have patents
is so that information gets shared so
you have to have a sharing of ideas to
drive invention but it's not again it's
not just invention innovation is not
just invention innovation is also
application it's taking those that that
invention and applying it well how do
you do that well you've got to focus
your organization so you have this thing
where you have collaboration and you
have focus again so if you look at
collaboration being critical for the
invention part of it on the people side
of it how do you promote collaboration
well it's your culture on your personal
networks for your structure your
organizational structure it's creating
liaison devices create opportunities
within your within your organizational
structure for that collaboration to take
place looking at on focus again from on
the personal level on the human level
how do you focus an organization you
focus it with leadership and motivation
and then from a structural standpoint
again organizational design standpoint
how do you focus the activity as an
organization well it's your management
structure that does that and I'm going
to now go back to buggy and give you
examples of you know again from you know
begin by very you know personal examples
back in the late 80s of our organization
and to bring home those points so the
first one starting on the people how do
you get her in there right that's a
question that anyone just about anyone
who's done buggy you know in some of you
doesn't nobody walks by during a
freeroll practice to erase everyone's
like is there somebody in there you know
like having of course you know it's not
robotic right but for us we had a really
really big problem I'd mentioned before
that ql and our buggies after that are
these carbon fiber monocoque so their
tubes well if you have a tube how do you
get her in there well one of the simple
things to do is say oh I'll cut a hatch
into it as soon as you cut cut a hatch
into a buggy oh it's a tube it's no
longer two but it flexes right so it was
like so we knew what we wanted to do we
knew we had the materials
we wanted to build it out of carbon
fiber and for the life of us we just
could not figure out how to get her in
there we couldn't figure it out so how'd
that happen well these are pictures when
i said to elizabeth was happy tom and
happy willie and it was it was Tom and
Willie and what they were doing one day
was what you're in gray banner right and
skibo but thank God doesn't exist
anymore Skiba was a really really awful
student union but these guys you know we
had a really really collaborative
environment and spirit buggy we were all
everyone was always everything was open
people are always welcome to the buggy
room we were always exchanging ideas and
that's kind of what we were about
culturally we also a really motivate we
really wanted to win so we were kind of
a little crazy about it and so we were
always thinking about and there's Willie
and Tom sitting there one day and great
men are just going over I'm trying to
figure out trying to figure it out and
Willie was an architect he's kind of
drawing curves and all of a sudden they
figure it out Oh what you can do is if
you you know instead of cutting a hatch
you kind of have an angle on the front
of the buggy you still have enough
enough a carbon fiber that you keep the
tude solid then the problem becomes and
then you can basically he slides in over
the wheel so now we didn't have the
problem didn't have to take the wheel
off like you did with a lawn we did
destroy the tube because of the front we
then had another technical problem which
was okay how do you make that windshield
right because and then you know but we
got it it took us a year but we got it
we got good windshields on it and again
that was the buggy that set the record
and held it for 20 years so a culture
this culture of collaboration was really
important to us but another thing on
this kind of personal networks about Tom
and about Willie's how did they get part
of spirit right how Tom got involved is
Tom ran cross country and track with my
roommate who was the other chair of
spirit buggy buoy I'll talk a little bit
more about things that amazing things he
was able to do so there's this personal
connection we knew tom tama done buggy
before for esta SDC and we needed
someone who had spiky experience we like
Tom so through that personal network he
got involved in the organization willing
it was kind of similar stories of
personal network Willie was again a
buggy guy he had actually worked for
fringe and
for a bunch of reasons was kind of
dissatisfaction and he was a chairman of
fringe and we knew him because he played
I am football with ray Jones and renew
all ray Jones from spirit so there's all
this kind of again was his personal
connection and we found Willie and will
he needed a home and wanted to do buggy
so here it sits using your personal
connections using who you know and you
know how do you go out and connect with
people and collaborate and and this
culture between the two of the things
we're able to create this collaborative
environment that brought Tom and Willie
together which solves our problems
liaison devices I mention again these
mechanisms these things these tangible
things that you can create to really
help collaboration and for us it was two
things one with spirit house which is
where our buggy room used to be and it
was a really open environment and there
was a hammock in there and there were
chairs in there and you know we were
living in there anyway practically but
you know and we'd also was kind of
interesting is is most buggy
organizations were really really
secretive okay because of the whole
proprietary knowledge but the basement
of spirit house was also with the washer
and dryer were so we had people always
in and out and they just created this
really really open environment and it
was a big part of creating a space or
help you know that helped us collaborate
and the other one margaret morrison 127
was my where um was we're booing and I
and actually Dave sours that's where we
thought our dorms right so they're on
campus the door was always open and we
were always people in our dorm we were
always talking about bug again it was a
place of safe place a collaborative
space where we could really bring us all
together it's also how how Dave showers
got involved in our organization can he
was the chairman who set to set the
record boolie again my roommate happened
to knows dave was I think two years
behind us in school Dave shows up first
weekend at school and he has a toolbox
with him there you go his fate was that
and he could snap a football so then he
was on our IM football team but his fate
was sealed from that
and then actually the and then David and
ended up being our roommate as well so
not only you know your Laird natalie was
bullying either but dave was there so
the whole the whole margaret morrison 11
27 was and would a collaboration space
for spirit buggy leadership and
motivation so i mentioned fully a couple
times this is doing Robert Bowie Colonel
Robert Bowie actually and you know when
i'm around spirit folks spirit buggy
folks and i'm at a particularly
expansive mood i can always say uh you
know none of you would be here if it
wasn't for me and he's the only person i
can't say that about right so when he's
in the room i can't i can't say that and
he was the co-chair with me and just
really just a master at leadership a
master of motivation i'll tell you what
he did to me one day it was early on our
first year and we were just awful and we
couldn't get anyone to show up we didn't
know we're doing you know and I'm
competitive and you know I wanted to do
well and we're trying to build a shell
for the first buggy we built called
Genesis and we're using fiberglass and
I'd never use fiberglass before and for
those of you who've never used it before
make sure you're really covered head to
toe with clothes because if you're not
the little glass fibers break off and
then they get into your skin and its
really really really painful right so
uncovered head to toe in fiber nobody
showed up the front you know we had the
wrong foam to wrap it around and look
really awful that we did use it right
and I'm just in pain and I'm really
really upset and I'm like okay I feel
awful there's no ever going to be
successful this is an awful thing so
back in mine and Morrison 127 I'm the
only respite I could get was to be
submerged in water so I'm like up to my
neck in the bathtub you know I'm just
kind of lying there because I had water
didn't hurt quite as bad and then fully
hook you know pokes his head around the
corner and I'm really mad right now I'm
going on I'm going on about this person
didn't show up and this person didn't
show up and we can't win and we can't be
competitive I'm like expecting him to
push back on me and he's like you know
you're
you're right yeah you're right yeah okay
yeah yeah yeah and so after my 15 minute
tirade or whatever finally I'm like boo
a kiss I just can't do this any was this
stupid I'm not going to do this I quit
he's like oh absolutely man he's like I
see where you coming from he said you
know I do the same thing so I made a
commitment what ah you know as soon as
he said you could see it like there was
a big button and he was pushing it and
he's like and I'm like all right you
know you got me you know let me get
leadership right personal leadership and
then you know that was a way to motivate
me right another part of another of my
Maya kind of on leadership stuff is this
is now the 87 buggy book where we talked
about a three year plan we did we really
had a three year plan which was first
year we were just going to go out there
and learn second year we're going to be
competitive third year we wanted to win
everything and that's really what we
said it right and again so the
motivation the leadership and this was
coming from both from both me and Bowie
was we're not there to have the fastest
push dreams we're not gonna have the
best drivers we're not there to have the
best buggies we're doing this to win
that's what we want to do let's focus
our energies of it and what had happened
that year was that once a year my last
year was a year we built quantum leap
okay beautiful beautiful buggy people
poured their souls into this thing and
blood literally a lot of my DNA is in
that buggy I bled on that buggy and you
know in our mechanics and you see a
bunch of them Dave and Tom and a few
others were so I mean that was they were
splitting immersed in making that buggy
happen and they did we got it built only
problem was the only driver we had who
could fit into the buggy lasell Bisbal
had never driven a car and had never
been bicycle and and she was awful
driver really sweet woman but just an
awful driver right and it was like you
know so billion I get a look at what's
the leadership the leadership is worked
here to win we're not here to put a
pretty buggy down you know the course so
here's our brand new spanking buggy and
I met you when you do buggies there's
ABC's and D so your age your top bugger
your your top team and down on is all
our mechanics you know Tom included
though it had to be the a buggy it had
to be the a buggy and we just made the
decision no it's not and what I did I
remember pulling this guy can more about
personal networks and recruiting bill
Mullen
and Bill Mullen lived in Margot Morrison
a few doors down from us and brilliant
guy math major comp sci guy and by his
last semester at CMU he had no classes
you know independent research and that's
all he was doing and he was a good guy
he was good with his hands and we wanted
to do something so we pulled him into
the organization as a mechanic and then
when everybody else is falling in love
with quantum leap was ql i pulled villa
side i'm like ok bill this is sting this
is your buggy make this thing work this
is our a buggy and nobody else is going
to show it any love and make this thing
hum and he did you know that's the buggy
that we won with right so yeah
motivation and leadership you know it
works it's certainly important with
buggy it's important than the you know
the new product development is stuff as
well management structure all buggy
teams have a little bit different
management structure this happened to be
ours were billionaire with co-chairs
when we brought when Tom within the
organization he was so difficult and
criticized everyone so much we had to
give him a special role because he was
right he just was very critical so Tom
became our vice chair and our inspector
general and what was a really wonderful
thing was other people started to step
up right for Nancy st. Louis nancy was
what five seven right and just too tall
to draw I me too tall to driving on our
top buggies you just couldn't fit in him
she loved drive and she was really
really competitive a stellar story
earlier about this book I mentioned when
I told you Genesis got into a record we
went Tom's worst weekend when all three
buggies got wrecked and one of them
buggy flipped over us well she was
driving that buggy and her leg sticked
out of the back of the buggy and we had
no back on it so we had to cross her
ankles together and taped her ankles
through the push bar so she was really
tough and a really good driver but again
she just could it be our a driver and so
she decided that she was going to be the
driver chair she decided and she was
great and she organized God all the
drivers of show before push practice and
all that sort of stuff was great st.
similar kind of story with Tom Killeen
he stood up and was a guy became her
push kept me he wasn't the fastest
pusher he wasn't the best for sure
matter of fact was a seat teen pusher
but he organized all the push practice
and really got involved as well he want
to do it somewhere story with Denise
Redmond is a flagger she stepped up and
did all that got our committee
mechanics and the other part of art this
is it all this is kind of dating this is
from a public enemy song but s1w is just
soldiers of the first world but these
are guys who they didn't really want to
do buggy but there were friends of us
but they showed up like the last weekend
and drove the truck and you know got
stuff done and was really really helpful
so all these people stood up and we
really did have a management rector
again all the teams have a little bit
different but but that was ours saying
and just to finish it up tool yeah julia
is the buggy people laugh right it's on
those special training and tools as
being these coordinating mechanisms
clearly it makes sense that there's
tools and buggy and everyone who doesn't
knows buggy than those that the most
important tool in the buggy room is duct
tape although although actually spirits
case the most important tool in the
bugging room is this piece of wood but
has to do with how we build our buggies
and it really does say the most
important tool in the buggy room is
written on is written in marker on that
self but it's not just tools you really
do have training and you really didn't
have practice all the time so this is a
part of the organization in and buggy so
based on you know the buggy or any of
that I have that conception of what
innovation is me you know when an
organization is from from the activity
theory stuff and use it through buggy
I'm this is the stuff I can say is you
know if you're kind of create an
innovative organization to do an
innovative task the most important thing
is to people so you got to recruit
talented people you got to retain him
you gotta motivate them right then
you've got to have you know a culture
and you got to have these mechanisms in
place that really encourage
collaboration that this is a really
really important part of an innovative
organization you also need to have all
the motivation and leadership and
structure that you have collaboration
but you have focus you focus on on
making the things that aren't really
applying it you need to have that and
then of course you have to give your
folks the right tools in the right
training to go along with that so it's a
conclusion you know as I've kind of try
to give you at least a conceptual or a
couple different reception models for
innovation and then used in New a little
bit about new product development and
then use primarily buggies an example
you know I think I can now say this you
know is that all anybody needs about
innovation is to do buggy so it's not
just you know I don't think I don't that
I certainly know I see up people from
other organizations it's my experience
and experiences
spirit back in the 80s is we're not the
only ones so thank you if anyone has any
questions now we're yeah how do you have
a really relaxed and collaborative
environment for people to kind of talk
with each other and brainstorm yet like
keep people motivated to actually
accomplish something in other words you
know as a manager how do you balance you
know having people be in a collaborative
environment that actually work right and
I actually I think that's probably that
the biggest challenge right is in some
ways that invention and collaboration
and that application focus our kind of
antithetical right you know one thing
let's go down this path and it's going
to do it and the other thing you're
saying oh let's explore right and to be
able to balance those two can be really
difficult my experience I mean my own
personal experiences both doing buggy
and then was when I was a technical
manager at a pretty big group at praxair
was to be really open with people and
really direct with people and and and
first of all I mean have an environment
where you really told I mean I would you
know tell people and you know and my
meetings at praxair that yeah I'm the
manager but I know I don't have all the
right ideas you know just because it's
coming out of my mouth doesn't mean it's
right so push back against me throw out
your ideas and you know and just
encourage people to think and encourage
people to explore stuff but at the same
time that I did that I was also really
really clear explain here's what's going
on with the company or here's what's
going on with our department this is
these are the needs of our customers we
got to do this so for me it you know
with just a lot of a lot of
communication and when and being really
genuine about being collaborative right
don't just say I want you know that's I
think a mistake some some companies make
as they say oh we want to be
collaborative when you want your
employees to really speak up but they
never actually do anything and they
never actually really listen to people
so it's to you know incursion
to say things and really listen to them
at the same time being really really
clear for their needs Ryan yep well you
have a very big flavors like either but
your your target from a couple things
and there are and actually Nikes not a
competitor in this space but there are
sketches as a competitor they put 40
million dollars into this into these in
there's a Pacific it's a specific niche
these well this shoe saw their shoes
that are designed to make you look and
feel better and so it's a specific
category so really it's really exciting
category grew like eight hundred and
fifty percent last year but the big
players in that space are our reebok and
or the major companies are about Reebok
and Skechers and for us the way we
differentiate ourselves is there's some
technology differentiation and all that
but we come in we come in as a very very
high-end shoe we try to present
ourselves kind of as the BMW in the
market so it's certainly high priced but
it's also really high performance and
really high quality and so the price
point for our shoes runs around 250 to
300 bucks where it's half the price for
those other guys so our idea is you know
let those other guys do all the
marketing let them you know put it in
all these um you know Stacy's and all
these other you know shops and what
we're going to do is we're going to keep
our thing really elite and only sell in
certain high really really high end
stores and and back up with a lot a lot
of quality and a lot of performance so I
actually think when for me since we're a
startup company we don't have a lot of
money I actually really liked the fact
that there's big players there because
you know I want people to know about
wellness shoes and I want them to try
and I want them to wear a pair of
skechers and say these are really cool
but I fell apart after six months and
let me step up and they'll maybe go to a
higher grade mm-hmm what else I think
more I just a more directly I mean give
you a more practical answer uh what we
spent a lot of time on really focusing
is a lot of guerilla market
stuff a lot of internet stuff a lot
we've gotten a lot of press about our
shoes because we just you know we're
connected into wouldn't connected into
there's only a few there's a few people
who cover the footwear industry for the
US and trade publications will really
tight with them and so you know we try
to you know find the right specialist
and the right experts and work with them
yeah what's your how well we do we do a
little bit of what's kind of nice to our
shoes are Korean right and r in Korea a
sponsor of the Korean Olympic team for
in Vancouver so certainly what's all
over our literature now is any time you
know the skaters were up there wearing
their gold medals that were wearing a
wet white jacket and over here it said
red so we try to do a little bit of that
ourselves I mean it's not you know it's
not high profile enough that we can get
you know I was were saying Michael
Jordan but the equivalent of whoever
Michael Jordan is to do that but you
know we try as much as we can and try to
be clever about it and in cheap be
honest yeah so back to the place you
know encouraging a Catalan buck but
productive work environment as a leader
of an organization you know a lot of
time to deal with people who are kind of
plate you know people who say they're
sit right and you know in the cause but
then turns out that you know they don't
come and do it they're supposed to do
and this applies them you know many
situations need a different organization
so my question be like how do you as a
leader as a manager how do you kind of
instilled passions
yes it's a great question um no it
really is a great question I don't think
you can and still passion I mean I think
and the motivation has to come from the
person I think you can encourage it and
fan it like if you find that spark when
you know if someone really has that
spark in there really are interested you
can really help them and really you know
give them a good role and give them
responsibility and and really listen to
them and if you find out that you know
yeah they say the right things but they
really don't have that spark I think you
just have to shut them off to something
that's simple and easy to do and and you
know for I know if someone really
doesn't have that spark i don't i don't
know if you can create it but you need
to identify it i mean you need to know
you need to you know you need to really
know your people and you really know is
this is this somebody who really is
going to step up and if i work with them
i can really help fan that motivation or
something somebody that no matter what i
do they're just not gonna be able to do
what i need and then you gotta move on
so reading people and again and how do
you do that is really talk to people and
really listen to them yeah
well two things he had it work better um
that's what we had and that was the
choice right I mean I reason I got
involved in that business is it came to
us is an investment bank right and was
one of you know whether or not we were
going to invest in the bank or invested
in the company and so I really looked at
it I fell in love with the product and I
fell in love with the category so it
wasn't like so it wasn't that I was
sitting there saying oh I'm a footwear a
guy I want to go into wellness footwear
hmm you know do I want to be skechers
don't be fit flops do I want to be
ridden do I want to be on VT for me it
was relatively limited that that you
know from so from a strategic standpoint
we had we had the product that we had
and it was going to be that product and
then once we had that to me it was a
really great advantage it really was
like the beautiful shoes and they're
really really well made so it's just
kind of sort of strategy in terms of how
we market it came from the product that
we have and honestly came from the fact
that it was a start-up we just don't
have a big marketing budgets so you know
we had to be creative about how we did
it and had to get it to the right people
I mean one of the things that was really
important has been really important to
us was identify within our customer
segments meniscus into kind of strategy
is for us given our ability you know
it's relatively hard for us to producer
we can't produce huge quantities of
shoes and all that and they're expensive
there's a category of foot retailers
called comfort stores and they're
usually local stores been around forever
very high technical sales they sell
relatively expensive shoes and those who
became our customers and because they
were logical to us because you know we
fit we felt that we could serve them and
we felt that we could give him something
that was really beneficial because our
shoots up pretty high margins there's a
lot of points to them and all that and
we wanted to and then we know them very
well and we want to be really good
customer to them and part of you know
again from a strategy standpoint is what
do these guys really need and the
service of course they you know they
don't want to pay and all that first
thing certain things he can't come but
if you give them the right you know
point sales per point
materials if you give them reasonable
terms a few big things for us actually
has been to give these people no
minimums a lot of times people say okay
you have to have a minimum order of 100
shoes that's really hard to get people
to start especially now so let's be you
know a good customer or assuming a good
vendor to these folks and say there's no
minimum order another big thing we've
tried to do strategically given what's
we once we realize that that's who we
wanted to you know the customers or yeah
customers we wanted to go after is we
identify people who are key thought
leaders in that industry and got them on
our side and got them to you know to
saying we have a segment that was on
Lifetime TV which is one of the leading
guys in this industry talking and raving
about our Footwear so you know identify
those folks this is does that kind of
answer your question or yeah yeah now
we're having to pay again it's a
guerrilla marketing summit guerrilla
marketing thing but we're having on
we're doing a special thing for nurses
week which I don't know exactly what it
is but it's coming up sometime the next
couple months
because you know this industry is just
growing and it's very risky to move into
more than one market um yeah I mean I
know I mean I think it's a little bit
more than a gut feeling I think that's
part of it I think part of it is a
traffic what the book is a Malcolm
Gladwell book blink where you know it
kind of talks about at least what I got
out of the book is there's kind of two
primary ways that is human being through
problem solve and one is the rational
intellectual like let me think through
it let me analyze it let me get all the
data let me you know be logical no but
another part of its kind of intuition
and it was to me the point of this book
was both of them can be wrong there's
lots of examples when intuition
intuition is wrong and there's lots of
examples when hard analysis is wrong but
when the two of them together lineup
then you have something so i think it's
it's looking at it from both it's having
that gut and making it feel right but
then also challenge your gut
intellectually and really thinking
through it and if you can't articulate
in a real clear manner why you want to
do something then we don't do it so you
know so it probably starts with the gut
but then backing it up with with the
detail you know more rational analysis
yeah
the question was like instilling in
passionate employees how do you maintain
passion with yourself like you're your
own see you seemed he was very
challenging for girls do the balls that
are you maintaining your direction your
photos especially my cash um okay uh let
me answer it or answer a different
question first and this kind of gets
back to again how do you how do you how
do you motivate people or how I think a
big part of it is something i did a lot
of when I was at practices I did a lot
of recruiting I went back to Minnesota
for 15 years of did PhD recruiting right
and so I got it and I also when I was
and I hired a lot of people right so I
got a lot of experience doing it and I
think one of the ways you know you find
you know motivated people is is not to
try to is to find people who are really
motivated is is you know is talk to
people understand them and find people
who are really motivated and
self-motivated to begin with it's
probably the best way of maintaining
motivation in your organization is fine
the right people now in terms of you
know how do you how do you keep going
yourself how do you keep motivated I you
know I guess I think that I articulated
this I think earlier which is I think
you just have to recognize it's never as
good as you think it is never as bad as
you think it is you just got you know
you gotta you gotta be engaged but
you'll also need to know that it's a you
know it's a long journey internet I
think at least for me intellectually
knowing that it's a journey and knowing
that there's going to be pitfalls
somewhere in it allows you to handle the
pitfalls better when they happen and you
see any others okay then thank you
you